[Music]
please welcome chairman of the
television Academy Frank Sherma
good morning and welcome to the
nomination announcements for the 75th
Emmy Awards we're here at the Hollywood
Athletic Club the legendary venue that
was the location of the very first Emmy
Awards back in 1949. it's amazing to
think the television Academy has been
honoring excellence in television for 75
years and what a great way to recognize
the importance of the writers the
performers and all those who created
such phenomenal work over the past
season we hope the ongoing Guild
negotiations can come to an equitable
and Swift resolution
we are committed to supporting a
television industry that stands strong
in equity and where we can continue to
honor all the incredible work you do
this morning I'm here with a very
talented emmy-nominated actor Yvette
Nicole Brown
for joining me to celebrate both the
great work of this year and the 75th
anniversary of the Emmy Awards are you
ready to do this ready it's so exciting
nothing makes me happier than
celebrating other people on their big
day so let's do this go for it all right
here are the nominees for outstanding
talk series
The Daily Show with Trevor Noah should
be happy that an African leader is
peacefully leaving power
that's never a guaranteed it's never
guarantee Jimmy Kimmel Live on in 20
years it is
it makes no sense I know it's ridiculous
late night was Seth Meyers
yeah one more time it was so fast just
one more time happy holidays
The Late Show was Stephen Colbert I want
my trials I want it
you were supposed to provide me six
weeks of delicious content
I wanted to see Rupert Murdock put his
hand on the Bible and burst into flames
the problem with Jon Stewart I'm
presuming you're gonna say it's Firearms
no I'm not gonna say it like it's an
opinion that's what it is it's firearms
congratulations to the nominees for
outstanding talk series
here are the nominees for outstanding
reality competition program
The Amazing Race
RuPaul's Drag Race
[Music]
Survivor
when service ready go it's on you
if I was ready
Top Chef
chats you have three minutes to get five
ingredients only
the voice well now this got awkward
excuse me prophecy this is for
television
is it
[Applause]
congratulations to the nominees for
outstanding reality competition program
here are the nominees for outstanding
lead actors in a limited or Anthology
series or a movie
Lizzie Kaplan Fleischmann is in trouble
Jessica Chastain George and Tammy
Dominique Fishback swarm
Riley Keough Daisy Jones and the six
and Ali Wong d
congratulations to the nominees for
outstanding lead actress in a limited or
Anthology series or movie
here are the nominees for outstanding
lead actor in a limited or Anthology
series or a movie
Taryn Edgerton blackbird
Kumail nanjiani welcome to Chippendales
Evan Peters Dahmer monster the Jeffrey
Dahmer story
Daniel Radcliffe weird the Al Yankovic
story
Michael Shannon George and Tammy
Steven young beef
congratulations to all the nominees for
outstanding lead actor in a limited or
Anthology series or movie
here are the nominees for outstanding
limited or Anthology series
there's some kind of warning show you
you trying to Blackmail me I don't want
anything from you okay I don't want
anything to do with you you are sick
you're a disease so you think you're
better than me now huh Dahmer monster
the Jeffrey Dahmer story something was
going on and you know what you did y'all
did nothing
nothing Daisy Jones and the six
[Music]
Fleischmann is in trouble Wayne is still
developing all right excuse me we've
already talked about it okay how about
my anxiety that everybody is always on
it and leaving me out she has a point
yeah
Obi-Wan Kenobi
[Music]
leave us alone when the time comes he
must be trained
like you trained his father
congratulations to the nominees for
outstanding limited or Anthology series
here are the nominees for outstanding
lead actor in a drama series
Jeff Bridges the old man
Brian Cox succession
Kieran Culkin succession
Bob Odenkirk Better Call Saul
Pedro Pascal The Last of Us
Jeremy Strong succession
congratulations to all the nominees for
outstanding lead actor in a drama series
here are the nominees for outstanding
lead actress in a drama series
Sharon Horgan bad sisters
Melanie lynskey Yellowjackets
Elizabeth Moss the handmaid's tale
Bella Ramsey The Last of Us
Carrie Russell the Diplomat loved her
and Felicity
Sarah snook succession
congratulations to the nominees for
outstanding lead actress in a drama
series
here are the nominees for Outstanding
Drama Series
and or
don't matter what you tell me you would
tell yourself
you'll ultimately die fighting these
bastards Better Call Saul let Justice be
done though the heavens fall
I didn't marry a family I married a man
I married you because I loved you
House of the Dragon
and now you take my son's bite into even
that you feel entitled exhausting wasn't
it
hiding beneath the cloak of your own
righteousness
The Last of Us
it wasn't time that
succession you do peace be a fresh start
for all of us we'll make things better
when it starts there
all you have to do is
vote Yes and support the deal
the White Lotus be honest I did
you did yellow jackets
congratulations to the nominees for
Outstanding Drama Series
here are the nominees for outstanding
lead actress in a comedy series
Christina Applegate dead to me
Rachel Brosnahan The Marvelous Mrs
maisel
Quinta Brunson Abbott Elementary
Natasha Leone Poker Face
Jenna Ortega Wednesday
congratulations to the nominees for
outstanding lead actress in a comedy
series
here are the nominees for outstanding
lead actor in a comedy series
Bill Hader Barry
Jason Siegel shrinking
Martin Short only murders in the
building
Jason Sudeikis Ted lasso
Jeremy Allen White the bear
congratulations to all the nominees for
outstanding lead actor in a comedy
series
here are the nominees for outstanding
comedy series Abbott Elementary I don't
believe in the moon I believe that
gluten intolerance is just internalized
white guilt glutenant and real Stevie
Wonder Hey blind you know Bill Gates
enough
Barry
because I love you what'd you say I said
I love you
Hey Barry yeah
I gotcha
what the is this what the is
that
this is my station this is not respect
no Chef that is not respect
hey
jury duty he's done X-Men Sonic he's in
Hairspray 27 Dresses uh Death at a
Funeral
um have you seen all those films no The
Marvelous Mrs maisel four minutes okay
four minutes you hearing me yes four
minutes four minutes four minutes you
got four minutes four I am gonna punch
you in the nose I don't care how it will
look on TV I'm thinking about doing
something only murders in the building
what this
this is you know I wish I thought of it
really I mean I wouldn't have gone as
far but what commitment huh really I
don't blame the player blame the game
bruh no don't do that
destroy everything Rupert loved and
owned and coveted ultimate Gangsta
Legend and admittedly that was me back
then
Wednesday she's allergic to color
oh flesh peels off my bones
congratulations to the nominees for
outstanding comedy series
and of course congratulations to all the
nominees for this year's Emmy Awards you
can find the full list of nominees
online at emmys.com tune in for the 75th
creative arts Emmys currently scheduled
to air on Saturday September 16th at 8pm
on FXX and join us for the 75th Emmy
Awards currently planned for Monday
September 18th at 8 pm Eastern 5 p.m
Pacific on Fox thanks to everyone who
joined us this morning I had the best
time oh this was great this was so good
thank you thank you
thanks for being
here everybody